a woman found dead inside a storage unit
in the northwest valley now many are
asking how could this happen as the
investigation into the incident
continues it's also identifying a
problem people living inside these
places joe mohler joining us live now
from the storage facility on centennial
parkway and durango joe
the woman has been identified as
59-year-old natalie burris she was found
here yesterday in one of these units we
don't not know how she died or why she
was here police say she was apparently
living in one of the units here i spoke
to a consultant for a number of storage
facilities who says there are typically
a number of security measures in place
to ensure people are not living in units
metro responded to the storage facility
owned by cubesmart monday morning police
say a woman was found inside a locked
unit by someone who knew she was there
an online rep from keepsmart's website
told me the gates are monitored with
specific hours according to the website
gate access hours are only through 10 at
night sherry sutton is a consultant for
a number of other storage facility
companies around nevada and california
this is one of the reasons why most
facilities don't offer 24-hour access so
usually the office hours have a
different set of hours than the actual
access to the units
and that's because 24 hours a day
you don't want people on your property
in the middle of the night police say a
number of people were living in the unit
anthony barnes from the salvation army
says people are resorting to libyan
storage units as an example of the
struggles some are facing the struggles
are really intensifying as the cost of
living just continues to increase it
presents a bit more of a gap
between those who are in need of housing
those are in need of services
and the services themselves
back out here live metro also did say a
lot of drug use was happening in the
unit as well i tried to contact the
company that owns this cubesmart they
have a number of facilities around the
valley i went to another facility to see
if we could get some contact information
for the corporate office the email they
gave us did not work we're reporting
live joe moulder live local now